I want to ask what might sound like a
sort of silly question but I think it's
particularly relevant given what's going
on
is Donald Trump dumb or merely a liar
the most likely answer is probably a
combination of both but we'll look at it
piece by piece the White House tweeted
yesterday during this hearing involving
FBI director James Comey and NSA
director Michael Rogers tweeted that the
FBI and the NSA told Congress during
this hearing that Russia didn't
influence the 2016 presidential election
that's not true okay and let's put up
the tweet that was involved here from
the official POTUS account where the
POTUS Twitter account said the NSA and
FBI tell Congress that Russia did not
influence the electoral process and
you'll see that there's a video embedded
in this tweet from the hearing but what
is actually in the video does the video
reflect what the POTUS Twitter account
said is in the video no it does not take
a look so my question as of today Emma
Rogers do you have any evidence that
Russia cyber actors change vote tallies
in the state of Michigan no I do that
but I would highlight where and foreign
intelligence organization not a domestic
intelligence organization so it would be
fair to say we are probably not the best
organization to provide a more complete
answer how about the state of
Pennsylvania yes sir the state of
Wisconsin no sir
state of Florida no sir state of North
Carolina no sir the state of Ohio no sir
so you have no intelligence that
suggests or evidences suggest any votes
were changed and nothing getta rated by
the National Security Agency sir so
again what Mike Rogers actually says is
we have no specific evidence that
Russian actors flipped votes during the
election with the caveat that they
aren't actually even the authority on
that sort of question that's drastically
different path than what Trump tweeted
or the White House tweeted which is Mike
Rogers said Russia didn't influence the
election two totally different things
well it's also a complete straw man
because no one's arguing that they
actually hacked into voter machines and
changed the tally correct it was more
about spread
information some true some not true in
order to affect people before they get
into the voting booth
another example okay here is another
tweet from the official President of the
United States Twitter account presumably
run by Trump or his staff linking to a
clip of an exchange between congressman
trey Gowdy and James Comey and what the
tweet says is FBI director Comey refuses
to deny he briefed President Obama on
calls made by Michael Flynn to Russia
so again does the video that the White
House is tweeting reflect what the tweet
says preview no it doesn't let's take a
look at the video did you brief
President Obama on I'll just ask you if
you breathe brief President Obama on any
calls involving Michael Flynn I'm not
going to get into either that particular
case that matter or any conversations I
have with the president I can't answer
that call me just refuses to comment
period he did I'm not going to comment
about briefings that I may or may not
have had with presidents of the United
States the tweet says Comey refused to
deny it and is sort of using that to
draw some kind of implication call me
did not comment I don't know if this is
alternative English some kind of
alternative fact do you think that this
is Trump or whoever is running his
account is it being dumb or is it being
a liar knowing that many of your
followers won't realize that what you're
saying isn't actually what was said in
the videos I think it's deliberately
misleading because I think they know
that Comey can't just speak openly about
this this is in a public setting and
it's an ongoing investigation so to try
to use his non answer there in an
appropriate non answer and try to use
that to bolster your own argument it's
just it's completely different later in
the hearing they actually asked Comey
about what the POTUS Twitter account
tweeted regarding his earlier comments
and both Comey and Rogers basically
responded saying yet that that's not
actually what we said healthy skepticism
about what our officials tell us
important that's not what I'm saying
what I'm saying is that with Trump even
basic facts or assertions can't be
believed even seemingly innocuous ones
including Trump not being truthful about
golfing and vacation in which we're
going to get to next